[Musique]
pour une amour qui passait par là j'ai
perdu la tête et puis me voilà pour une
amourette qui se posait là pour une
amourette qui me tendait les bras pour
une amourette qui me disait bien j'ai
cru qu'une fête dans ses dans mes mains
pour une amourette qui faisait du
bonheur j'ai fui la planète pour
laassailleur alors je me suis dit tu es
au bout du chemin tu veux t'arrêter là
tu reposer enfin et lorsque l'amour s
noyé dans ses yeux j'ai cru que je
venais d'inventer le ciel
BL pour une amourette qui m'avait souri
je me suis très honnête j'ai changé ma
vie pour une amourette qui savait
m'aimer pour une amourette qui croyait
m'aimer pour une amourette l'amour
éternel dure le temps d'e fête le temps
d'un saleil et mon amourê quiit trop
jolie faire d'autres conquêtes bientôt
reparti le premier àieu a garder son
secret elleemporte l'amour me laissant
les regrets mais not viux printemp loin
refleurissait contre mon cœur déjà il me
disait une petite amourette pour la
prendre comme ça un jour de peut-être
longtemps quelquefois pass sécher tes
larmes un nouvel amour te guêter des
armes peine d'Ang jour une petite
amourette un jour reviendra te tourner
la tête te tendre les bras chanter la
romance du rêve g et je sais d'avance
que tu diras oui Alors les amours pour
toi repleuriront tu aimera encore à la
belle saison une Pete amourette n jamais
trop jolie quand on sa
d'avance ce que dure la
vie
[Applaudissements]